bien chers collègues je vous propose que
nous reprenions le cours normal de nos
travaux je rappelle que
nous recevons ce matin
messieurs Léonet directeur général
adjoint de la police nationale et
Monsieur lutte directeur central de
recrutement et de la formation
nous nous inscrivons dans la suite et
probablement la fin des auditions menées
par la mission d'information sur la
formation initiale et continue de la
police et de la gendarmerie nationale
mission qui a été confiée à maïs Carrère
et Madame Catherine Di Folco elles sont
toutes les deux rapporteurs
messieurs de textes récents la loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère intérieur et le projet de loi
sur les jeux olympiques et paralympiques
ont un nouveau mis en lumière un certain
nombre d'ambitions mais de besoin aussi
en termes de recrutement et de formation
de nos forces de sécurité
nous savons que
[Musique]
les écoles manquent de moyens matériels
voire parfois de formateurs qu'il est
difficile de recruter des jeunes dans
les profils soient parfaitement adaptés
aux missions des forces de sécurité nous
savons qu'il est difficile aussi
d'organiser la formation continue des
personnels enfin tout cela ne savons que
la police et la gendarmerie sont
mobilisés sur ces questions et quand
même admettre et reconnaître que des
progrès ont été faits clairement en
matière de temps consacré à la formation
initiale et continue mais également
aussi en matière d'accent mis sur la
police judiciaire nonobstant les
questions du moment sur le sujet
je vous propose de vous donner la parole
tout de suite ensuite il y aura sans
doute des questions et puis
vos collègues gendarmes nous rejoindront
je pense en cours de route on leur
donnera la parole lorsqu'ils arriveront
naturellement
ils sont
et
ils sont en route mais peut-être
s'occupent-ils de gérer ça bien
merci
beaucoup c'est président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
je suis accompagné de Philippe Lutz qui
est le directeur central du recrutement
et de la formation de la police
nationale et qui sera en mesure
d'apporter toutes les précisions à mon
propos je vais peut-être simplement dans
le prolongement de ce que vous venez de
dire monsieur le Président vous vous
direz un peu quel est l'ambition
aujourd'hui de la police nationale dans
le domaine de la formation une ambition
forte puisque
par la vertu du vote du Parlement la
police nationale a été dotée de moyens
supplémentaires de moyens humains
supplémentaires et qui dit moyen humain
supplémentaires doit dit recrutement et
formation donc pour nous d'abord premier
élément une progression quantitative
assez marquée
de nos recrutements je le cite pour 2023
un schéma d'emploi lourd
4180 gardiens de la paix recruté à
former et
3570 policiers adjoints bon c'est un
vrai challenge tout à l'heure Philippe
Lutz vous dira les efforts qui ont été
déployés par le réseau notre réseau de
la formation pour arriver à encaisser
cette ce programme
aujourd'hui nous sommes en mesure de
dire que nous parviendrons à y faire
face nous y parviendrons à la fois par
une montée en puissance de notre de nos
capacités d'accueil mais aussi par une
montée en puissance de notre réseau de
formateurs
avec de bonnes idées de bonnes pratiques
qui ont été développées pour nous
permettre d'encaisser ce choc je vous ai
parlé des gardiens de la pêche je peux
vous parler aussi des officiers puisque
vous le savez compte tenu de
l'importance des départs en retraite
nous avons un plan de recrutement de
d'officiers de police qui nous a amenés
à en recruter l'année dernière
à peu près 400 et qui pour cette année
en 20223 nous permettra d'en recruter
460 qu'il faut que nous incorpions on
est en progression de 12% par rapport
aux incorporations 2022 pour les
commissaires de police même challenge 94
servir de police a recruté et à former
cette année c'est 30% de plus que l'an
passé augmentation qui s'explique
notamment par l'importance des détachés
que nous allons que nous allons être
amené à recruter
je cite également
et l'arrivée de nos camarades de la
gendarmerie me permet de citer un
dernier vivier important de recrutement
pour nous que sont les réservistes
opérationnels puisque la police
nationale dans l'esprit qui anime nos
camarades de la gendarmerie depuis
plusieurs décennies la police nationale
se lance dans un recrutement important
de réserviste opérationnel
nous en avons formé en 2022 1150 et nous
avons un plan de charge qui sera de 2500
réservistes opérationnels à forme et
chaque année à partir de cette année
une mention puisque c'est aussi une des
ambitions portées dans la loop me une
mention sur le cyber le cyber est un
vrai sujet de recrutement et de
formation pour la police nationale de
deux points à citer auprès de vous
d'abord très très concrètement dès cette
année ça va être le changement d'échelle
de notre Service Commun police enfin
gendarmerie police dans le domaine du
numérique qui était jusque là le
stsi et qui va devenir l'Agence
Nationale des forces de sécurité
intérieure très concrètement pour la
police nationale ça veut dire à l'été
150 policiers formés sur ces sujets du
numérique pour rejoindre cette agence
voilà pour ce qui est de cette amélior
enfin de cette progression quantitative
de nos recrutements
un point sur l'amélioration qualitative
du recrutement et de la formation vous
le savez c'est l'allongement de 8 à 12
mois de la formation des gardiens de la
paix avec un objectif entre autres ça
n'est pas le seul mais il est important
de former nos gardiens de la paix de
mieux former nos gardiens de la paix à
la mission investigation à la mission de
police judiciaire
puis plus de vous dira tout à l'heure
que les premiers résultats qui sont qui
sont engrangés dans les dans les écoles
de police nous montre une j'allais dire
un bon écho une bonne réussite
de ces premiers des premiers examens
qu'on a pu faire passer à nos élèves en
école une bonne appétence sur le
judiciaire et nous pensons que nous
arriverons
probablement alors selon des proportions
sur lesquelles je reste très très
prudent mais que nous arriverons à avoir
en sortie d'école comme le ministre de
l'Intérieur la souhaiter
des gardiens de la paix qui pourront
passer le bloc OPJ augmentation aussi de
la formation initiale des policiers
adjoints de trois mois nous passons à
quatre mois et puis je le mentionne des
formations initiales très spécifiques
mais qu'il a aussi répondent au cahier
des charges qui est celui de la loopnie
une formation spécifique pour les
assistants d'enquête vous le savez les
assistants d'enquête sont ces personnels
administratifs dont nous souhaitons
qu'il puisse apporter aux enquêteurs
toute l'aide dont ils peuvent avoir
besoin sur des tâches matérielles qui ne
sont pas strictement des tâches
d'enquête mais qui permettent de
décharger les EPG et de les de leur
permettre de se consacrer un peu mieux à
ces missions d'enquête les assistants
d'enquête que nous allons recruter sont
des personnels à qui nous feront
bénéficier d'une formation et ce sera
une formation commune police et
gendarmerie
aujourd'hui on est sur un module d'au
moins 5 semaines c'est pas encore
totalement fixé on est toujours en
discussion mais au moins cinq semaines
de formation pour ces assistants
d'enquêtes et puis je mentionne un
deuxième vivier en substitution qui est
celui des personnels que nous voulons
déployer aux aubettes vous le savez dans
les aéroports aux aubettes nous avons
aujourd'hui des policiers des policiers
ou des policiers adjoints nous
souhaitons pouvoir le ministre de
l'Intérieur nous a demandé de développer
une substitution pour que des personnels
contractuels et des personnels
administratifs puissent accueillir les
passagers dans les aéroports aux
aubettes le plan de formation tel que
nous sommes en train de le fixer
aujourd'hui nous permettra d'avoir au
moins deux semaines de formation pour
que ces effectifs puissent se consacrer
à cette nouvelle mission ce qui est
intéressant en plus pour les personnels
administratifs puisque aussi bien la
mission des assistant d'enquête que la
mission aux aubette leur permet d'avoir
de nouveaux débouchés ce qui est dans la
police nationale est toujours et
toujours intéressant des objectifs en
matière de formation continue enfin je
le mentionne vous le savez le ministre
de l'Intérieur dans le cadre de la
locmin nous a demandé de faire
progresser de 50 % la formation continue
donc ça c'est un programme ambitieux sur
lequel Philippe lus reviendra je
mentionne aussi dans la formation
continue les fameuses formations
obligatoires qui seront dès cette année
les formations obligatoires pour les
passages de grade de brigadier-chef et
majeur voilà un mot sur le fait que nous
développons aussi
des formations conjointe avec nos
camarades de la gendarmerie notamment
dans tous les secteurs
spécialisés de police judiciaires mais
pas seulement nous avons aussi une
ambition importante de travail en commun
dans le domaine du cyber la gendarmerie
a ouvert une école du cyber à Lille sur
laquelle elle a proposé à la police
nationale qui l'a bien évidemment
accepté de pouvoir avoir des formations
communes donc nous avons avec nos
camarades de la gendarmerie des
programmes qui sont des programmes là
aussi importants de formation conjointe
voilà ce que je pouvais vous dire d'ores
et déjà et je suis évidemment à votre
disposition pour répondre à vos
questions
merci Monsieur peut-être
au généraliser tout de suite en général
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs donc
s'agissons de la gendarmerie beaucoup de
choses partagées bien évidemment avec la
police nationale j'insisterai sur
quelques points je considère que nous
avons actuellement 3 enjeux majeurs
s'agissant de la formation de nos
gendarmes au sens large
le premier enjeu c'est de renforcer leur
militarité leur robustesse et leur
polyvalence parce qu'on s'aperçoit que
la complexité la dangerosité des
interventions le justifie le deuxième
enjeu c'est de former nos gendarmes au
numérique ou de moins ou du moins de les
sensibiliser pour certains et d'en
former d'autres et le troisième enjeu
face aux augmentations d'effectifs que
nous sommes ravis d'avoir dans les
années à venir c'est de développer le
capacité de nos écoles parce que nous
allons être amenés à recruter comme nous
n'avons jamais recruté au cours au moins
des 30 dernières années
s'agissons de la formation initiale nous
insistons beaucoup nous continuons
d'insister sur la formation militaire
général à la robustesse au mental au
physique qu'elle soit tactique ou
qu'elle soit individuelle nous
travaillons donc au cours de la
formation initiale beaucoup en lien avec
les armées et nous continuons de
développer des partenariats avec les
armées pour que chaque élève gendarme
puisse être formé à des programmes de
robustesse de manœuvres techniques à
l'échelon du groupe parce que sur
certaines interventions nous avons été
confrontés à de véritables scènes de
guerre
à titre d'information ce sont 80
formations que la gendarmerie suit en
abonnement auprès des armées que ce soit
des formations initiales ou des
formations continues nous développons
aussi beaucoup le concept du gendarme
polyvalent les papillons des unités de
gendarmerie qui est spécifiques quand
même à la gendarmerie fait que le même
gendarme au cours d'un même service ou
du même journée peut être confronté à
ces situations différentes et donc à ce
titre nous essayons de renforcer la
formation pour avoir pour répondre aux
gendarmes primo engagés qui pendant les
15 premières minutes sur tout événement
sera par définition seul donc à ce titre
quel que soit les dominantes choisies
par nos gendarmes ils reçoivent tous une
formation au maintien de l'ordre à la
sécurité routière à la police judiciaire
il faut que dans ce socle partagé toutes
les dominantes soient pleinement
acquises ce qui ne fait pas obstacle
bien entendu ensuite à des unités à des
formations spécialisées
formez aussi nos gendarmes au métier de
police de demain c'est continuer à
développer l'intervention
professionnelle chacun sait que face à
la dangerosité des interventions face
aussi à leur médiatisation il faut que
les gestes professionnels soient
parfaitement maîtrisés dans l'intérêt de
tous que ce soit celui du délinquant
comme celui du militaire est toujours
dans un souci de de sécurité et de juste
emploi de la force nous avons pas mal
développé aussi au cours des deux
dernières années et nous continuons à
développer tout ce qui est lutte contre
les violences sexuelles sexuelles
sexistes et les discriminations et
évidemment conformément aux souhait du
président de la République nous
renforçons notre formation en police
judiciaire depuis le mois de septembre
dernier tous les élèves gendarmes
rentrant en école font un mois de plus
donc ils font 9 mois désormais en école
puis 3 mois en stage pour arriver à moi
le dernier mois étant consacré à
renforcement de la formation officier de
police judiciaire pour être clair la
partie théorique de l'examen d'officier
de police judiciaire leur est désormais
enseigné pendant leur formation initiale
et bien évidemment c'est ensuite dans
les deux années suivantes en unité qu'il
devront envelopperont la partie plus
pratique de la formation au PJ avant de
pouvoir être habilité officier de police
judiciaire
nous avons un programme ambitieux
parallèlement de sensibilisation ou de
développement du numérique alors il y a
le programme cyber pour tous ce qui veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui tout élève gendarme
rentrant en école à une formation au
numérique étant entendu que le domaine
numérique représente à peu près
aujourd'hui 15% de du volume de
formation d'un élève gendarme mais
au-delà de ce cyber pour tous nous
développons ce que nous appelons des i
compagnies ce sont des compagnies de
volontaires de Jean enfin d'élèves
gendarmes volontaire qui ayant déjà une
appétence pour ce domaine vont avoir
pendant leur scolarité une formation
allongée et renforcée dans le domaine du
numérique je ne reviens pas sur l'école
du cyber dont nous avons parlé mais je
peux préciser qu'à côté de tout cela
nous avons considérablement aussi
développer l'enseignement à distance
puisque l'éparpillement de nos unités
sur tous les points du globe fait que
beaucoup de formations peuvent enfin
méritent d'être pour partie au moins
faites à distance à titre d'informations
ce sont 787 formations que nous
proposons dans un enseignement à
distance par un train net et 787
formations représentant quand même 2700
modules pédagogiques donc ce n'est pas
rien nous ne faisons évidemment pas que
de la formation à distance mais
aujourd'hui dans beaucoup de formations
il y a une partie faite à distance en
amont d'une partie faite dans les écoles
en présentiel
s'agissons maintenant de notre capacité
à auxquelles je faisais allusion dans
mon propos introductif il faut savoir
que désormais nous avons mieux distingué
depuis un an ce qui ressortit de la
direction des personnels donc que j'ai
le plaisir de diriger de ce qui ressorti
des écoles nous avons mis en place un
opérateur de recrutement et de formation
au sein du commandement des écoles et
nous continuons à développer tout ce qui
est formation initiale et continue nous
avons créé des centres régionaux
d'instructions dans chacune des 13
régions de France et dans chacun des
territoires enfin des dans chacune des
collectivités d'outre-mer de sorte
qu'une partie une grosse partie de la
formation continue et désormais des
volumes maintenant aux échelons
régionaux ou assimilés qui viennent en
complément nos 25 centres et écoles et
enfin je vous disais qu'on avait un
véritable enjeu capacitaire il faut
savoir que au moins pour les des années
2023 et 2024 c'est de l'ordre de 11 à
12000 personnels par an qui passeront
dans nos écoles
5200 à 5000 élèves sous-officiers chaque
année environ autant d'élèves gendarme
adjoint et le complément correspondant
aux autres recrutement ce qui nous
conduit à devoir augmenter notre
capacité en termes de compagnie
d'accueil dans les écoles l'objectif
étant entre 2025 et 2027 d'augmenter de
12 compagnies d'élèves l'ensemble de nos
écoles je rappelle que nous avions dans
le cadre des 20 dernières années du
fermé 4 écoles aujourd'hui nous n'avons
pas fait le choix de rouvrir des écoles
exilos mais plutôt de développer celle
existante et en particulier celle de
Dijon qui comptera 6 compagnies
supplémentaires ce qui n'est pas rien
sur la seule implantation de Dijon voilà
ce que je voulais vous dire en propos
introductif après maintenant je suis
entière disposition pour répondre aux
questions merci en général je vous
propose de donner la parole aux
collègues entre les premiers ou les
premières d'entre elles sont nous
rapporteurs madame difolco et puis
ensuite madame Carrère
monsieur le Président merci Monsieur les
intervenants je crois que vous avez vous
avez reçu un questionnaire pour guider
la préparation de cette audition donc on
va pas pouvoir égrainer toutes les
questions mais on compte sur une
production écrite de vos services afin
d'alimenter la fin de nos travaux
effectivement nous avions nous avons
avec Marie Carrère débuter cette mission
il y a fort longtemps puisque c'était en
te covid donc maintenant ça paraît très
loin le départ de notre mission je le
rappelle c'était les techniques
d'interpellation la comparaison entre
les la police et la gendarmerie voilà et
puis donc on a été obligé de
s'interrompre pendant presque deux ans
nous avons repris nos travaux l'année
passée et quelques peut modifier
le contour de notre mission est plus axé
sur la formation
[Musique]
la formation initiale de la formation
continue et nous avons fait plusieurs
déplacements dans les écoles et nous
avons toujours été extrêmement bien
reçus et nous avons appris énormément de
énormément de choses et nous tenons à
remercier vraiment toutes que ce soit de
la police ou la gendarmerie tous les
personnels qui nous ont accueillis nous
arrivons au terme de cette mission enfin
voilà
et nous pensons rendre un rapport et
sans doute quelques préconisations je
pense à la fin du à la fin de ce
trimestre voilà moi j'aurais voulu poser
une question parce que c'est un peu
l'arlésienne c'est à Monsieur Lude
peut-être
l'académie de police
qu'est-ce que c'est cet académie de
police c'est quoi les contours de
l'académie de police
quelle est la finalité on en entend
parler depuis longtemps mais
j'ai rien de concret il y a trois lignes
dans le rapport annexé à la loopy mais
voilà merci de ces précisions
[Musique]
les directs
de vous retrouver et pour cette audition
dans le cadre de du suivi de la loop me
alors effectivement comme l'a dit ma
collègue Catherine isolco on est ravis
de voir aussi que la loop me reprend un
petit peu ce que nous avions constaté
sur le terrain puisque nous nous sommes
rendus
nous sommes concentrés sur la formation
des élèves en gendarmerie en police et
la formation continue nous sommes rendus
dans des écoles de police et de
gendarmerie et nous avons aussi été
passé deux jours au centre formation
d'excellence centre d'excellence de
Saint-Astier pour
pour la gendarmerie je vois que le
rapport reprend dans ses annexes euh
le renforcement quantitatif et
qualitatif des formations et de façon
conséquente pour la police notamment ce
qui nous
rassurer et nous réjouir et on est en
tout cas
ravi de voir aussi la mise en forme de
de beaucoup de centres nouveaux alors il
y a énormément de prévisions et c'est
conforme au constat que nous avions fait
aussi des déficits d'école des déficits
de stand de tir et c'est vrai que quand
on lit le rapport il y a beaucoup de
choses qui vont être faites et ça va
créer
beaucoup d'activités pour pour la police
et la gendarmerie dans les mois qui
viennent pour la police le rapport
prévoit une augmentation de 50% de la
formation continue comment vous allez
absorber cette augmentation conséquente
parce que ça va quand même être une
organisation et il va y avoir un besoin
important de formateur je crois qu'il
est prévu plus de 1500 formateurs
supplémentaires est-ce que vous avez
prévu des mutualisations alors nous ce
qu'on aimerait savoir c'est les
possibilités de mutualisation entre la
police et la gendarmerie même si on nous
a expliqué qu'on était peut-être pas
tout à fait dans les mêmes cultures avec
les uns qui sont dans une militarité et
pas les autres voilà ce qui a quand même
des possibilités de mutualiser notamment
des équipements des équipements
techniques comme comme les stands de tir
est-ce que vous avez aussi prévu est-ce
que c'est souhaitable pour nous il
paraît que c'est important de faire
appel à des formateurs étrangers à la
police et à la gendarmerie ça existe
déjà un petit peu avec les magistrats ou
des avocats qui qui viennent intervenir
dans les écoles où le milieu associatif
est-ce que cela vous paraît envisageable
ou et comment ça doit être organisée
est-ce que c'est au niveau de chaque
école ou est-ce que c'est au niveau
national ou régional que c'est ces
mutualisations et c'est ces intervenants
peuvent être organisés je vous remercie
bien merci Monsieur général monsieur oui
avant de laisser
sur avant de laisser la parole à
Philippe Lutz pour détailler la manière
dont la la police nationale ou avec
laquelle la police nationale absorbe le
choc de ces progressions peut-être
répondre madame la sédatrice à votre
question sur l'académie de police en
restant très modeste dans mon propos
parce que tous les arbitrages n'ont pas
encore été rendus par le ministre de
l'Intérieur nous sommes toujours dans
une phase de préfiguration ce que nous
savons aujourd'hui c'est que le lieu a
été désigné par le Président de la
République c'est Montpellier nous savons
également que
l'option retenue n'est pas de faire un
seul lieu de formation pour l'ensemble
de la police nationale la police
nationale dispose aujourd'hui d'un
réseau d'écoles de gardiens de la paix
d'école d'une école d'officier d'une
école de de commissaire de police il
n'est pas question d'aller vers un
chamboule-tout pardonnez-moi
l'expression mais en revanche les tels
que
nous les soumettons aujourd'hui au
ministre de l'Intérieur serait plutôt de
créer avec l'Académie de Police un label
qui serait le label propre à tout le
réseau de formation de la police
nationale y compris dans des domaines où
nous sommes aujourd'hui en progression
très forte je pense à la formation
continue on peut tout à fait
imaginer que demain le réseau de la
formation
soutient avec Montpellier d'une d'un
lieu de formation continue assez
emblématique je vous ai parlé de
l'augmentation de la formation des
formations promotionnelles de
brigadier-chef et de major nous pourrons
évidemment avec cette académie de police
avoir un lieu important pour se
consacrer à ces formations et puis
dernier sujet qui est un sujet sur
lequel il faut avoir le netteté de le
dire la police nationale n'est pas en
avance c'est la recherche on a
aujourd'hui
à Saint-Cyr-au-Mont-d'Or qui est l'école
des commissaires de police
un petit service de recherche mais qui
n'est en rien à l'aune de ce qu'on peut
attendre
de ce que la police nationale de ce dont
la police nationale peut avoir besoin
dans le domaine de la recherche donc là
aussi l'académie de police sera le lieu
de main de
d'échanges et d'échanges croisés à la
fois avec nos partenaires en interne
mais aussi à l'international sur ce
domaine de recherche voilà je ne suis
pas plus précis que ça pour des raisons
qui sont encore une fois des raisons de
d'arbitrage non encore rendu par le
ministre intérieur ce que je vous
propose peut-être c'est de demander à
Philippe plus de nous expliquer comment
le réseau de la formation aujourd'hui
encaisse la progression des formations
continues
merci alors
l'objectif de formation continue depuis
50 ans
l'objectif de 50% d'augmentation la
force la formation continue c'est un
objectif extrêmement ambitieux
alors l'idée un peu d'ailleurs comme la
formation initiale
c'est qu'on a eu c'est d'essayer de
réfléchir un tout petit peu différemment
il y a la réflexion traditionnelle sur
la formation continue c'est de dire les
gens se forment pas assez c'est en gros
c'est les feignants ils ont autre chose
à faire donc il faut les obliger bon
l'obligation de formation c'est très
bien que ça ne marche pas ça ne
fonctionne pas on trouve toujours les
bonnes excuses c'est un peu comme dans
la règle du jeu de Jean Renoir
l'embêtement dans ce monde c'est qu'on a
toujours de bonnes raisons et donc on a
toujours des bonnes raisons pour ne pas
se former et donc l'idée ça a été de
travailler à la fois mais ça je suis pas
très original en le disant sur le le
développement de la formation en
distancielle mais aussi de travailler
beaucoup sur la proximité c'est-à-dire
que on ne pourra pas empêcher entre une
action de formation et un concept
cambrélage ou des interventions sur des
violences conjugales on ne pourra jamais
dire que la formation est plus
importante à réaliser qu'une
intervention opérationnelle donc l'idée
c'est vraiment été de travailler sur la
proximité
c'est aussi de travailler sur
l'obligation de compréhension pour les
cadres de ce que la formation et au-delà
de la formation les compétences parce
que
ça parle beaucoup plus un vrai
gadier-chef un major un officier un
commissure de police de lui dire pour
accomplir les objectifs opérationnels
de quoi dispose-t-on au sein de son
service de quelles compétences
dispose-t-on au sein de son service de
dire que une action en matière
judiciaire
elle est indispensable c'est est-ce que
mes effectifs disposent des compétences
judiciaires nécessaires et donc la
réflexion elle doit être menée déjà à ce
niveau là quand je parle de proximité
c'est aussi tout le travail de fait dire
de réappropriation locale de formateurs
c'est-à-dire ce qu'il y a de plus
efficace c'est pas de dire aux gens de
se déplacer à 20 30 40 50 km pour faire
une séance de formation alors pour un
stand de pour une séance de tir comme ça
a été évoqué là on est contraint par des
objectifs immobiliers mais ce qu'on a
déjà évoqué sur tout ce qui est
technique d'interpellation
il est sans doute beaucoup plus efficace
d'avoir sur place sur un temps mort
d'activité et notamment en matinée de
pouvoir concentrer les effectifs en
équipe pour leur réapprendre leur faire
finalement de leur faire d'avoir une
progression en matière de technique
d'interpellation avec des des situations
qui leur sont fournies et du debriefing
et du réflexe qu'il aurait donné
directement donc en fait les axes de
travail sur la formation continue plus
50%. c'est à la fois développer le
distanciel on a un y campus où on a
actuellement quasiment 160 000 inscrits
avec et au-delà des inscriptions ce qui
est important c'est la fréquentation à
la fois régulière et le nombre de gens
qui se forment au moins une fois sur lui
campus chaque année on a alors en terme
de fréquentation on a une moyenne de
4000 fréquentations jour de
fonctionnaires avec des plus de 7000
fréquentations et on a en moyenne à peu
près 120 000 fonctionnaires qui se
forment chaque année sur le yampus donc
ça c'est encore une fois c'est la
nécessité d'avoir une offre qui soit
adaptée en permanence qui soit évolutive
le deuxième aspect au-delà du et c'est
aussi une réflexion liée à la proximité
c'est l'accompagnement
dire que on va tout faire en distanciel
c'est à mon avis méconnaître l'acte de
formation il y a nécessairement à un
moment un accompagnement et je vous cire
d’exemple très précis
qui rejoint un tout petit peu d'ailleurs
la question de l'ouverture de la
formation
il y a maintenant quelques mois j'ai
reçu les deux associations de policiers
qui sont partiellement investis dans la
lutte contre le suicide donc qui sont
aps et peps pour qu'elles puissent
intervenir dans les écoles de garde la
peste qui est fondamentalement pas
évident je veux dire quand vous rentrez
dans l'intérieur de policiers qu'on est
une association qui vous parle du
suicide dans la police ça peut
apparaître un tout petit peu quelques
quelque part contre-productif bon on a
fait ce choix avec le directeur général
et le dire CPN de pouvoir les faire
intervenir on a une première
intervention il y a quelques semaines
maintenant à Périgueux qui a
parfaitement fonctionné
alors pourquoi j'évoque ce sujet parce
que lors de notre entretien
ils m'ont évoqué une vie formation qui
est obligatoire pour tous les fonctions
de police qui a été réalisés à la fois
par le NSP et par la décès FPS sur le
repérage des signaux faibles de
situations pouvant entraîner et engager
sur un suicide et ils m'ont évoqué le
fait que l'Institut de la formation
était parfaitement faite mais à un
moment pour certaines personnes elle
pouvait engager une réflexion sur des
situations qu'ils avaient déjà vécu et
bon c'est une appalissa de dire ça mais
quand on est en formation distancielle
on est seul face à son écran et seule
façon à son écran si à nouveau on a des
réminiscences de situations
professionnelles qui ont pu être
traumatisantes c'est peut-être compliqué
à vivre alors c'est une formation qui
est encore une fois extrême mais l'idée
c'est d'avoir alors c'est tout à fait
policier ni lié à la gendarmerie mais
quelqu'un qui puisse un moment faire la
médiation c'est à dire de pouvoir
accompagner dans un certain nombre de
formations distancielle les stagiaires
qui vont suivre ces formations pour leur
donner des éléments alors il y a des
choses qui existent puisque on a des
forums des changes entre les différents
stagiaires sur les ft6 sur les OPJ sur
tout ce qui est cyber sur tout ce qui
est investigation numérique ou les
fonctionnaires les stagiaires échangent
de manière régulière mais nous semble
nécessaire encore une fois d'accompagner
beaucoup plus le distanciel ce que fait
par exemple parfaitement bien le CNFPT
le CNFPT a beaucoup développé à la fois
le distanciel mais aussi le tutorat en
matière de formation en distancielle
quand je parle de proximité l'idée c'est
aussi beaucoup de travailler sur encore
une fois le service
de pouvoir utiliser des micro-formations
une formation c'est pas obligatoirement
5 jours c'est pas le batteur en 3 jours
c'est pas obligatoirement deux heures ça
peut être quelque chose qui va durer une
demi-heure ou une heure et c'est encore
une fois extrêmement important d'avoir
cet accompagnement local
alors concernant la formation continue
sur les stands de tir question qui a été
évoquée le la mutualisation existe déjà
largement avec la gendarmerie elle
existe avec les centres privés et les
polices municipales puisque c'était
c'est une question avec une limite qui
est celle de la possibilité d'avoir un
certain nombre de conditions
de sécurité en matière de tir qui sont
validées alors pour ce qui nous concerne
par les amis et donc la commission qui
doit passer systématiquement pour
vérifier la qualité du centre de tir et
puis bon je pars dans les détails
techniques mais quel type de cartouche
va-t-on tirer est-ce que le stand de tir
est suffisamment étendu pour pouvoir
accepter ce genre de choses mais cette
mutualisation à l'effet depuis déjà
longtemps par la force des choses parce
que ni la police ni la gendarmerie de
bénéficie de suffisamment de stand de
tir et le besoin il est tout à fait
considérable
les mutualisations avec la gendarmerie
elles existent déjà sur un certain
nombre de thématique le directeur
général l'a évoqué sur tout ce qui est
investigation investigation numérique
tout ce que nous propose la gendarmerie
notamment sur
la lutte contre les infractions liées à
l'environnement
toute la formation encore une fois liée
au stub dans le cadre de la création de
l'ofast et puis ça a été évoqué
rapidement la formation des assistants
d'enquête va être mutualisé avec la
gendarmerie alors les possibilités elles
sont larges le fait que d'un côté on est
la militarité de l'autre côté que la
police ne développe pas toujours les
mêmes doctrines c'est effectivement un
sujet mais c'est un sujet qui peut
naturellement être largement discuté et
les lieux de formation peuvent aussi à
mon sens tout à fait être mutualisé même
si tant du côté police que du côté
gendarmerie
les sites sont quand même très largement
occupés actuellement donc mutualiser des
espaces qui sont déjà limités peut
apparaître compliqué mais il y a une
volonté véritablement partagée de
pouvoir mutualiser ces compétences
dernier sujet qui concernait les
interventions extérieures
c'est un peu lié d'ailleurs avec
une remarque qui a fait le directeur
général sur la recherche
moi on est très attentif à cet aspect là
parce que c'est un reproche qu'on fait
beaucoup à la police de pas assez être
ouverte sur l'extérieur alors en terme
de formation effectivement comme la
gendarmerie nos formations sont assurées
par des policiers parce que mais les
policiers qui ne sont pas des
professionnels de la profession de
formateurs puisqu'ils ont une durée
limite pour exercer la fonction de
formateur et dans tous les cas la
formation c'est deux choses c'est à la
fois la formation à la pédagogie nos
formateurs sont formés pendant 12
semaines à l'AS pédagogie la gestion de
groupe mais ils sont aussi avant toute
chose des policiers qui ont exercé sur
le terrain et donc ils peuvent apporter
leur expérience et leur expertise du
terrain bon il n'empêche que
sur un certain nombre de domaines on a
développé alors bon on l'avait déjà
évoqué les interventions de Flag du
défenseurs des droits de la dilkra de la
lycra qui interviennent de manière
régulière et avec lesquels on a
travaillé ça c'est important encore une
fois l'idée c'est pas seulement de
l'avoir une espèce d'affichage en disant
flag le Défenseur des droits intervient
bon c'est très bien on est très ouvert
et tout ça c'est de travailler avec eux
sur la progression pédagogique
c'est-à-dire que le Défenseur des droits
n'intervient pas de manière à n'importe
quel moment de la scolarité il
intervient à un moment donné et on a
travaillé avec lui son intervention la
solution de facilité aurait été de dire
bon le Défenseur des droits présente ce
qu'est le Défenseur des droits bon voilà
c'est un intérêt relativement limité ce
qui est intéressant pour nous c'est de y
compris quand c'est gênant quand ça
gratte un peu de les faire intervenir
sur des situations qu'ils ont eu à
traiter ou des policiers sont intervenus
et de leur intervention à poser problème
et donc la présentation du Défenseur des
droits elle est fait en distancielle
avant donc tous les élèves ont
l'obligation préalablement de pouvoir se
connecter sur l'Espace Numérique de
Travail pour savoir concrètement quel
est le statut du défense sur les droits
à quoi il sert comment il organiser tout
ça et le délégué du Défenseur des droits
quand il intervient parle de situation
extrêmement concrètes qu'il a pu avoir à
traiter ou que le Défenseur des droits
dans sa généralité peut avoir à traiter
et ça c'est à mettre en parallèle avec
toutes les situations professionnelles
qu'on analyse exemple type je crois
qu'on l'a évoqué lors du passage de la
Commission on travaille alors pas au
début mais après la période de stage sur
des vidéos que le monde est Médiapart
avaient relayé concernant des contrôles
d'identité filmé à partir des caméras
piétons
et qui sont pas totalement à la gloire
de la police il faut être clair
le tutoiement sur le contrôle d'identité
tout ça et ça nous semble encore une
fois important et d'autant plus
important que c'est les policiers
eux-mêmes qui filme ça avec leur caméra
piétons de montrer que il y a certains
noms à la fois de techniques et
d'agissement qui ne sont pas conformes à
ce qu'on attend d'un policier dans sa
vie quotidienne et ça encore une fois
j'ai récemment ça doit montrer une sorte
d'ouverture de la police nationale dans
sa formation à ce que l'on peut pouvoir
montrer à chacun
merci
parce que Madame Di Folco la parole et
après je donne la parole aux collègues
qui l'ont demandé
nous recevons des personnalités ce matin
pour les auditions importantes s'il y a
des discussions privées elles peuvent se
faire dans le couloir
vraiment je suis désolé d'en arriver là
mais d'ici j'entends absolument tout ce
qui se passe et c'est assez désagréable
pour tout le monde et en particulier
pour ceux qui interviennent alors je
suis vite fait la police monsieur je
suis bien entouré pour ça mais j'ai la
police de l'audience la circonstance on
va pas délivrer les mandats de dépôt
tout de suite mais vraiment si un sujet
particulier allait dans le couloir enfin
je suis désolé d'en arriver là vraiment
ça me nave même du Folco merci président
oui peut-être renforcer la question de
ma collègue Maryse et peut-être Maryse
tu me corrigeras si je dis une bêtise
mais lors de nos auditions et notamment
de magistrats il nous a été dit que dans
le cadre de la formation OPJ il serait
peut-être intéressant que des magistrats
interviennent parce que une finesse
c'est eux qui reçoivent les PV et qui
doivent les interpréter prendre des
décisions etc et peut-être que les PV ne
sont pas forcément rédigé de
très bonne manière pour qu'il puisse
être éclairés dans leur prise de
décision
ultérieure je crois que c'était ça
Maryse un espace
insister sur ce point-là merci alors
formation initiale elle a été déployée
sur la première promotion
qui est en cours qui est la 26e
promotion qui est rentré en mai 2022
elle se déploie en deux temps premier
temps durant la période de scolarité
avec un contrôle national judiciaire qui
représente qui est la suite de quatre
semaines de formation et donc ce
contrôle national judiciaire qui compte
pour 300 points sur les 1000 points du
classement général a été réalisé et si
l'audition avait eu lieu
vendredi j'aurais pu vous donner avec
certitude les taux de réussite donc pour
le nombre de d'élèves qui avaient le la
moyenne on est pour l'instant les
estimations sont aux alentours jours de
60 65 % de taux de réussite donc c'est
c'est 60 65% d'élèves qui ont la moyenne
feront le deuxième module OPJ donc
normalement quand ils seront enfin c'est
pas normalement lorsqu'ils seront en
stage sur la fin de l'année 2023 donc
Novembre Décembre pendant 8 semaines
avec deux semaines de distancielle et 6
semaines de présentiel ou des magistrats
interviennent naturellement et ensuite
il passeront l'examen au PJ au mois de
janvier 2024 de manière à avoir à coller
au plus près entre formation et
réussite passage de l'examen donc en
fait de manière très claire les
magistrats sont associés bon ils sont
associés naturellement dans la
commission PJ puisque la Commission au
PJ est présidée par un magistrat de la
Cour de cassation les magistrats
contrôlent les sujets qui sont donnés
tant pour la gendar pour la police
nationale aux examens et il participe
pour ce qui concerne la police à l'oral
qui est réalisée au moment de l'examen
au PJ sur un certain nombre de
situations de compte-rendu parquet et ce
genre de choses
bien j'ai 8 interventions donc Madame
l'herbier monsieur à Lamarque monsieur
Durand pour les trois premiers
passionnant ce que vous venez de nous
présenter
si vous permettez je vais appuyer vos
propos monsieur Lutz
par des exemples qui se passent dans le
Nord
compétences et proximité compétences et
proximité c'est essentiel alors la
formation initiale information continue
vous avez mis ça en place notamment à
Roubaix alors nous venons de faire un
colloque avec le commissaire principal
cadera roone et la directrice Madame
tchitchenko tous les deux montrent que
dans leur public c'est essentiellement
des gens qui profitent de l'ascenseur
social que leur offre la police et
quelque part c'est de l'optimisme que de
constater ça
beaucoup de jeunes sont venus à
cecologue des jeunes méritants des
jeunes très motivés à être dans la
police ou dans les gendarmerie ils ont
beaucoup apprécié les tutorats les
demandes tout à chacun s'est proposé de
les prendre en tutorat en stage etc
c'était très très apprécié
alors vous vous avez dit Monsieur lutte
la proximité
j'ai dirigé les études de l'iegi de
l'île et on a préparé les concours de
commissaire de police pour que les
commissaires soient issus du terroir
c'était ce qui était le plus difficile
pour nous essayer de les adapter à la
difficulté du concours ils avaient la
motivation ils avaient la compétence ils
avaient la formation mais il y avait le
petit truc en plus qui leur manquait
c'est à dire passer les concours ils
étaient pas habitués à ce genre
d'exercice et là
[Musique]
pourtant des classes d'écoles intégrées
ont été mises en place pour les épauler
je trouve que c'est admirable et ça ça
mérite de d'avoir de bons de bons
résultats mais véritablement il faut à
mon sens et je me permets de d'insister
là-dessus il faut vraiment insister
là-dessus que les commissaires
puissent aussi être originaires du
terroir là où ils vont être habitués à
travailler parce que une région et une
autre on a des mentalités complètement
différentes et là lors du colloque on a
vu que c'est qu'il y avait des jeunes de
qui étaient plus que partant à s'en
sortir donc à mon sens il faut leur
donner un petit coup de pouce
à lie aussi on a vu aussi beaucoup de de
jeunes qui n'arrivaient pas à passer le
concours de commissaire alors qu'ils
avaient les compétences comme je vous ai
dit
ne pourrions-nous pas essayer de trouver
des métiers passerelles tout le monde ne
peut pas être commissaire mais tout le
monde peut avoir un bagage qui peut-être
utile pour la police
je pense que ça on pourrait travailler
un peu plus cette histoire de de repérer
ceux qui ont peut-être les compétences
intellectuelles mais qui n'ont qui n'ont
pas
si vous voulez le savoir-être psychique
sur le terrain mais ça n'empêche que ça
peut être quand même des gens qui sont
extrêmement intéressants pour la police
enfin vous avez parlé
du flic de de ce qui est cybersécurité
et à Lille il y a le forum international
de cybercriminalité qui fait fureur vous
avez des classes d'ingénieurs qui
recrutent et qui proposent de rentrer
dans la police là je pense que dans
toute la France il y a des écoles
extrêmement intéressantes qui pourraient
être justement vous parlez de mutualiser
de partenariats je pense que vous êtes
en plein dedans de tout ce qu'il faut
mettre en place sur le terrain merci
madame monsieur Lamarque monsieur Durand
puis madame arrivée merci président ma
première question portée sur la
formation continue je crois que vous
avez largement développé sur ce sujet
ensuite je me réjouis du fait que vous
ayez parlé des caméras piétons c'est une
avancée considérable je crois que c'est
le Sénat qui a beaucoup travaillé
là-dessus qui aujourd'hui permettent
dans la pratique quotidienne de nos
policiers et gendarmes
d'éviter certains problèmes et surtout
souvent
de faire en sorte que les relations
entre l'interpeller et le gendarme ou le
policier soit bien meilleur et ma
question portera donc sur la cyber
sécurité et la cyber criminalité qui va
prendre de plus en plus sans doute
d'importance dans les dans les mois et
des années à venir est-ce que vous ne
trouvez pas que le cadre d'emploi de la
fonction publique d'État avec la limite
notamment la limite des salaires
ne vous permet pas ou le permettent pas
à des gens qui seraient intéressés
préférant aller bien évidemment vers le
privé qui
merci Monsieur Marc monsieur Durand puis
madame mariebet merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur une première question
à Messieurs Léona et Lutz sur
l'enjeu de pilotage de de cette
ingénierie de formation globale puisque
on voit qu'il y a des sujets
capacitaires pédagogiques immobiliers
enfin très nombreux
la Cour des comptes avait formulé des
observations sur l'architecture
budgétaire
de la dcrpn qui permettait pas un
dialogue de gestion et qui complique un
peu les choses il y avait aussi un sujet
je crois sur des dysfonctionnements de
l'info centre formation du système
d'information RH est-ce que ça c'est
résolu parce que comme on peut dépasser
ces sujets pour piloter l'ensemble des
défis qui sont devant vous deuxième
question c'est pour réitérer la question
qui a été évoquée par mes collègues
difolco et Carrère sur les techniques de
sécurité en intervention notre groupe
est extrêmement attaché au rapport
police population il y a beaucoup de
sujets sur les ref peu de tempérer sur
l'usage des armes vous nous avez fait
une réponse sur la mutualisation j'en
avais stand de tir mais globalement
quand on rencontre des policiers nous
disons du mal quand même à
pouvoir avoir leur
obligations d'entraînement remplies
est-ce que vous avez un pourcentage des
personnes électives qui ont réalisé
effectivement leur 3 séances de tir
et sur le taux de réalisation des 12
heures d'entraînement annuels
réglementaires et comment on peut si
c'est pas le cas actuellement sans que
tu arrivais ce temps le temps consacré
ses formations
merci Madame aribet et Monsieur Leroy
[Musique]
la diversification des profils de
formateurs j'aimerais avoir la réponse
de vous mon général par rapport à ce qui
se passe en gendarmerie c'est à dire
qu'on fait appel à des compétences de
plus en plus diversifiées en matière de
cybersécurité en matière de violence
intrafamila
[Musique]
quelle ouverture vous pouvez nous avoir
pour la formation et puis une autre
question sur la formation initiale
est-ce que vous pensez du fait de la
diversité des des compétences et des
expertises supplémentaires qu'on demande
est-ce que vous sauriez favorable à une
modification des des concours d'entrée
en particulier avec le renforcement d'un
bloc de connaissances juridique à
l'intérieur de des concours d'entrée
puisque si je m'abuse le concours en
épreuve écrite il y a culture générale
gendarmerie et études de textes côté
police est-ce que et puis après c'est
des tests psychotechniques et du sport
est-ce que est-ce qu'il faudrait pas un
bloc juridique de connaissances
juridique qui permettrait d'aller plus
vite après dans la formation initiale
comme dans la formation continue sur
laquelle vous avez beaucoup insisté
merci Monsieur Madame Monsieur Henri
Leroy puis ensuite monsieur Bourgi
oui pour être le plus rapide possible je
voudrais dire à ces messieurs que on ne
peut que se réjouir de tout ce que vous
annoncez puisque lorsque la commission
des lois avait conduit une enquête sur
l'état des forces de sécurité d'une part
et lorsque nous avons participé tous les
lundis pendant six mois au bobo de la
sécurité effectivement ce qui avait été
mis en évidence et qui avait fait
l'objet du rapport de la commission sur
le manque de formation
continue puisque lorsque nous avions
dans le cadre de la vie du budget était
tentanime qu'à
Dijon effectivement nous avions constaté
que l'ensemble des encadrants n'avaient
pas les moyens et n'avait pas le temps
de former raisonnablement face à
l'évolution des tâches de chaque agent
de police judiciaire et maintenant
puisqu'il y en aura pratiquement plus
des officiers de police judiciaires et
bien c'est vraiment je dirais un grand
bonheur d'entendre que toutes nos
préconisations ont été retenues ont été
d'une part
retransmise à l'ensemble des cadres
temps de la gendarmerie que de la police
et puis le seul fait d'avoir aujourd'hui
que des officiers de police du cerf
demain je dirais c'est vraiment
une multiplication des relations entre à
nos PJ qui a des relations permanentes
avec les magistrats donc voilà ce que je
voulais remercier c'est d'avoir en tout
cas que le gouvernement a pris
conscience je vous a donné
les instructions et que vous les mettiez
en application voilà ma question est
simple est-ce que dans les écoles où on
se connaît centre de formation vous
aurez les moyens tant matériels quand
personnel pour former raisonnablement à
cette évolution sociale que les agents
de les forces de sécurité sont
confrontés merci Monsieur Laurent
monsieur usine puis madame Benbassa
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président je
voudrais revenir sur le sujet académie
de police en ma qualité de Montpellier
instinateur de l'Hérault donc je me
réjouis de cette annonce qui a été faite
le contenant a déjà été identifié le
terrain a été trouvé en revanche nous
nous posons toujours des questions sur
deux sujets le premier sujet concerne
l'installation de la Direction centrale
du recrutement de la formation de la
police nationale et ses 200 27 agents à
Montpellier est-ce que c'est toujours à
l'ordre du jour est-ce que c'est
confirmé ou pas et la seconde chose nous
connaissions très bien
de police de Nîmes départements voisins
c'est la raison pour laquelle lorsque
l'académie de police a été annoncé
nous étions confrontés à la fois la
satisfaction d'avoir un service
important prestigieux qui s'installe
dans notre département dans notre ville
mais nous étions aussi traverser par la
perplexité qui était celle des policiers
et des organisations syndicales de
police nationale sur le terrain qui ne
voyait pas trop la différence qu'il
allait y avoir entre l'académie de
police nationale et l'école de police
nationale à Nîmes et tout à l'heure
lorsque vous avez fait part de la
modestie de vos propos quant à la aux
arbitrages attendus et à la phase de
préfiguration
plusieurs mois après le doute reste et
donc c'est un peu gênant que ces
annonces-là étaient faites et que nous
n'ayons toujours pas
la réponse ferme et définitive sur le
contenu de l'académie de police si c'est
uniquement un label et à transformer les
écoles de police nationale en académie
de police on n'a qu'à dire les choses et
ce sera très bien ainsi mais je pense
qu'on ne peut pas par respect pour les
policiers qui sont sur le terrain
laisser subsister cette période de doute
parce que j'ai eu l'occasion de
rencontrer un certain nombre des acteurs
des de l'école de police de Nîmes eux
aussi ne comprennent pas très bien donc
nous avons besoin d'être rassurés
j'entends bien que ce n'est pas vous qui
preniez les décisions ce n'est pas vous
qui rendez les arbitrages mais si à
l'occasion de vos travaux sur ce sujet
là vous pouviez nous aider à avancer ce
serait bien la seconde chose que je
voulais évoquer c'est la formation
qui est celle des policiers des
gendarmes à la fois en charge qui va
nécessairement augmenter
puisqu'effectivement à la locmi est
particulièrement ambitieuse ouverture de
200 brigade de gendarmerie dans les
prochaines années augmentation des
effectifs de police nationale il se
trouve que je suis délégué du CNFPT en
Occitanie et donc je travaille au
quotidien avec les policiers municipaux
mais aussi avec les policiers nationaux
et la gendarmerie qui nous demandent la
possibilité de venir éventuellement
s'entraîner dans les locaux qui sont les
nôtres donc ça sera naturellement avec
beaucoup de plaisir que nous les
accueillerons mais ceci étant dit en
discutant avec eux on se rend compte
qu'il y a à la fois des interrogations
sur le volume d'activité qui va
augmenter de manière arithmétique qui
dit plus de policiers recrutés plus de
gendarmes recrutés dit plus de gens à
former est-ce qu'aujourd'hui la police
comme la gendarmerie dispose des
formateurs nécessaires pour assurer ses
formations et deuxième observation ce
sera la conclusion de mon intervention
on se rend compte aujourd'hui de la
montée la puissance dans notre pays et
en tout cas la visibilité des violences
intrafamiliales et en milieu rural
c'est-à-dire en zone de gendarmerie nous
avons des zones blanches ou une n'existe
pas nécessairement d'associations
d'accompagnement des femmes victimes de
ces violences où il n'y a pas
nécessairement de structures
d'hébergement donc je tenais à vous
poser cette question est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui un effort particulier
étape est fait en matière d'accueil
et d'accompagnement des femmes et des
enfants qui sont les victimes
collatérales de ces violences
intrafamiliales et enfin et ça c'est la
question de l'accueil que ce soit en
zone de police ou en zone de gendarmerie
il y a un sujet qui est essentiel qui
revient systématiquement c'est la
qualité de l'accueil qui est dispensée
la plainte comprend ou qu'on ne prend
pas en disant déposer une main courante
et on reviendra plus tard là c'est ça
s'adresse plutôt à la police nationale
plutôt qu'à la gendarmerie et
malheureusement lorsque les drames
surviennent on se rend compte qu'il y a
eu parfois plusieurs main courante avant
que le sujet soit clairement traité donc
merci beaucoup de nous apporter des
éléments de réponse sur le volume et sur
le contenu des formations merci Monsieur
boursier madame Benbassa puis monsieur
Sueur terminal la liste des intervenants
merci Monsieur pour les informations que
vous nous avez apportées moi je poserai
une simple question sur le
contenu de la formation
est-ce que les les nouveaux gendarmes
les nouveaux policiers sont seront
formés à la discrimination et ce qui
seront formés à la désescalade lorsqu'il
y a des conflits on voit bien quand le
commandement est bien mené à Paris ces
dernières manifestations il faut le dire
je j'y vais souvent il y a un vrai
un vrai changement et on voit bien que
on discute quand même avec les
manifestants un peu nerveux
même violent il y avait des Black Blocs
donc ça a été fait d'une manière où il y
a pas eu de grave incidents ni de dégâts
corporels et est-ce que aussi il y a une
disons une sorte de sensibilisation
pour les nouveaux sujets qui
interpellent de plus en plus la police
mon collègue a parlé de l'accueil des
femmes et violentées par leur compagnon
ou leur conjoint et aussi voir ce qui se
passera avec les contrôles offensiels
c'est vrai que c'est caméra si elle
marche parce que il paraît que jusqu'à
récemment le marché pas très très bien
si elle marche est-ce que il y aura une
sorte disons de consensus sur les règles
de contrôle offensif voilà je vous
remercie merci Madame et puis Monsieur
Jean-Pierre Sueur
et
par rapport à cela je voulais vous
interroger sur la formation parce que
certes il y a la question de
l'entraînement au tir qui est très
important puisque d'ailleurs c'est un
sujet auquel nous auquel nous parlons
avec les duquel nous parlons avec les
élus s'agissant des polices municipales
d'une pas sérieux d'armée des policiers
sans qu'il y ait de longues séances
régulières et renouvelée je pense que
pour ce qui est de la gendarmerie de la
police nationale vous y veillez
particulièrement c'est ce que vous nous
avez dit
mais en dehors de cela il y a une
question de
maîtrise psychologie de réflexion sur
l'acte et c'est certainement très bien
de faire venir un certain nombre
d'organismes
humanitaires et
préoccupé des libertés publiques qui
peuvent dire toutes leurs toutes leurs
positions mais comment préparer vous
dans la formation
les gendarmes les policiers les
gendarmes
à l'acte ou à la situation précise
c'est-à-dire le la situation de stress
absolue où il faut prendre une décision
en une seconde et
moi j'y pense toujours parce que il y a
l'effet divers il y a les enfin c'est
pas les filles il y a les situations
qu'on a vu qui se sont d'ailleurs qui
sont plus nombreuses que il y a quelques
années et à chaque fois moi je me dis
ça devait être très difficile pour les
fonctionnaires policiers gendarmes je
mets leur place il est facile de
critiquer moi je me critique pas je dis
si quelqu'un est là dans cette situation
où il faut prendre une décision en
véritablement une seconde
c'est très difficile donc ça demande une
maîtrise très forte moi j'admire
d'ailleurs
vos collègues vos camarades qui exercent
ces missions parce que c'est facile de
créditiquer mais c'est très difficile
comme situation donc je pense que c'est
bien qui est des séances de tir mais
comment est cette situation si pratique
et psychologique est appréhendée dans le
cadre de la formation initiale et
continue
alors il y a pas d'autres questions ou
d'autres interventions c'est la parole
en général la visée à la parole avisez
pas je vais essayer de regrouper
ont bien évidemment je voulais insister
pour regrouper certains thèmes surtout
ce qui est partenariat j'ai beaucoup
entendu formateur extérieur
autre profil pour former nos gendarmes
oui bien sûr nous sommes convaincus du
besoin de ce partenariat alors je
précise que pour ce qui concerne la
gendarmerie au moins c'est pas tant sur
la formation initiale mais plus sur les
formations continues et techniques que
nous développons des partenariats nous
avons beaucoup de conventions avec des
universités des unes des utts de sorte
que beaucoup de formations internes à la
gendarmerie et parfois d'ailleurs
partagée avec la police nationale on
débloque qui se font en faculté
on se raccroche à des cours de BTS ou
autre formation selon le niveau de la
même manière sur des formations
techniques bien évidemment des
intervenants extérieurs à ces formations
sont à nos côtés sur des matières
extrêmement techniques mais je crois
qu'encore une fois il faut bien
distinguer ce qui est de la formation
initiale ce qui est du cœur de métier
qui a plutôt à vocation à être fait par
faite par des professionnels et de ce
qui est formation plus technique ou
évidemment il faut aller chercher les
professionnels de la technicité
vous parliez de cybersécurité et de
difficultés à recruter oui il est vrai
que la cybersécurité aujourd'hui est un
domaine extrêmement concurrentiel on
nous entend souvent des ingénieurs nous
dire que s'ils allaient dans le privé
ils toucherait un salaire avec un zéro
de plus alors c'est vrai ou c'est pas
vrai ce que l'on essaye de faire nous
c'est de développer au-delà de la
compétence de nos propres officiers en
la matière développer des contrats à
durée déterminée ou des CDI ou même à
vous des recrutements spécifiques de ce
qu'on appelle des officiers
commissionnés c'est à dire des officiers
qui ont déjà une technicité enfin des
civils qui ont déjà une technicité et
qu'on recrute comme officier
technicien dans leur technicité pour
combler des domaines dans lesquels on
pourrait avoir des lacunes alors bien
évidemment ça ne se fait pas non plus
tout seul on essaye au maximum de en
amont de développer des partenariats
dans ce domaine avec plutôt les écoles
d'ingénieurs de sorte que des ingénieurs
dans leur deux dernières années d'école
peuvent venir faire des stages chez nous
découvrir le milieu de la gendarmerie et
continuer à servir dans nos services
techniques j'observe quand même que même
s'il est vrai que dans le privé on peut
gagner plus bien souvent c'est une bonne
carte de visite pour eux et beaucoup de
jeunes ne rechignent pas à faire
plusieurs années dans la gendarmerie
peut-être qu'il a une même dans la
police de façon à avoir une carte de
visite avant de basculer dans le cellule
et puis on en a aussi qui viennent nous
dire que ils préfèrent ce qu'ils font
chez nous parce que chez nous ils le
font pour une cause commune ils le font
pas pour une entreprise
ils le font pour un bien commun il y a
heureusement encore des gens dans notre
société qui croient mais ce problème de
métier en tension dans la cybersécurité
il est évidemment partagé je sais qu'il
est aussi partagé avec les armées
puisque on travaille à la même question
avec les armées dans un domaine
concurrentiel enfin puisqu'il s'agissait
de formation externe sachez aussi que
nous développons les formations à
l'étranger nous les efforçons avec les
pays amis proches européens d'envoyer
des gendarmes en formation dans des pays
étrangers nous avons sorti au mois de
juin une promotion qui a suivi sa
scolarité à Madrid auprès de la
guardiative donc nos homologues
espagnoles nous le faisons aussi avec
d'autres pays nous le développons avec
l'Italie de sorte que une culture
commune avec des pays amis frontaliers
puissent se développer évidemment on a
des sujets partagés communs sur le plan
opérationnel ensuite
vous me posiez la question de savoir
s'il fallait augmenter le niveau
juridique pour parler large de nos
élèves avant même qui rentrent en école
dans nos concours alors je vais
distinguer les officiers des
sous-officiers je rappelle que nous
sous-officiers sont recrutés avec le bac
donc nous n'apposons pas des preuves
juridiques du fait que jusqu'au bas qui
a pas de culture juridique en revanche
dans les faits il est vrai que un bon
nombre de lauréats ont déjà quelques
années de facultés et souvent de
facultés de droits avant de rentrer
comme élève gendarme pour autant se
bagage juridique c'est bien pendant leur
année de scolarité qu'on leur donne
s'agissant des officiers nous avions
ouverts il y a une quinzaine d'années
une vingtaine d'années maintenant un
concours universitaire où on
s'apercevait que 90% des lauréats compte
tenu de la nature des épreuves qui était
avant tout juridiques étaient des
juristes nous avons depuis souhaité
diversifier le recrutement en ouvrant
d'autres voies plus scientifiques pour
éviter d'avoir une culture j'allais dire
monochrome de l'officier de gendarmerie
considérant qu'il y avait bien d'autres
enjeux et puis je crois que l'avenir
nous a donné raison en matière de cyber
en matière de de besoin d'ingénierie
dans tous les domaines et donc à ce
titre nous efforçons de développer
toutes les filières aujourd'hui sur ce
concours universitaire au sens large à
peu près la moitié de nos candidats sont
des juristes l'autre moitié sont plutôt
des des personnages enfin des ingénieurs
ou au moins des personnels de culture
scientifique et je crois que c'est
important de bien diversifier
vous nous avez posé la question de
l'augmentation des moyens relatifs à la
formation inhérente à la montée en
puissance et au 200 brigades donc je
vous confirme que donc dans la loop me
il est bien prévu des effectifs
supplémentaires au titre de la formation
pour être précis ce sont 252 et TP qui
seraient partiront à la fois entre nos
écoles de formation initiale pour former
12 compagnies supplémentaires comme je
le disais tout à l'heure et au profit de
nos centres régionaux d'instructions qui
eux sont axés sur la formation continue
davantage
en matière de vif de désescalade oui
bien sûr nos gendarmes reçoivent des
formations sur tout ce qui est
accompagnement vif parce qu'il est vrai
que dans des zones rurales nous avons un
problème et un trou dans la raquette
comme on dit en matière d'association et
de capacités d'hébergement et ça rejoint
ça fait quoi est-ce que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est le primo intervenant qui
est seul dans son unité qui doit être
équivalent donc oui il y a des
formations à l'accueil oui il y a des
formations vif mais au-delà nous avons
aussi mis en place des unités
spécifiques maisons de protection des
familles au moins une par département
souvent avec des relais des cellules de
protection des familles jusqu'à
l'échelon des compagnies de sorte que
dès que des dossiers deviennent un petit
peu complexes dans ce domaine des
gendarmes un peu plus spécialisés
puissent prendre le relais au plus vite
ce qui n'enlève rien
à ce qu'a pu faire le premier
intervenant enfin s'agissant de du souci
de désescalade nous avons toujours eu
soutien de l'ordre ce souci de veiller à
la désescalade je crois que ceux qui
sont allés au centre national
d'entraînement des forces de gendarmerie
de Saint-Astier ont pu le constater le
Light motif dans ce centre c'est que les
forces de l'ordre que nous sommes ne
doivent pas être celle-ci conduisent à
l'escalade d'une manifestation mais que
la riposte soit toujours graduée et
adapté à la menace donc je de mon point
de vue il y a pas grand chose qui a
changé dans cette approche depuis que ce
centre existe et sur nos conception du
maintien de l'ordre enfin en matière
d'usage des armes et d'augmentation de
du droit d'usage des hommes même si
cette augmentation du droit de l'usage
des armes mais discutable parce que bien
des mesures qui sont dans la nouvelle
loi figuré déjà dans le décret organique
du 20 mai 1903 qui régissait le droit
d'usage des armes des gendarmes on a eu
peu d'évolution en la matière oui nous
essayons autant que faire ce peu au-delà
du simple tir de former nos personnels
et de les faire réfléchir nous avons
notamment des vidéos avec des scénarios
qui sont présentés à des groupes de
gendarmes par un moniteur d'intervention
professionnelle on voit on a une
situation et on a qui finit sur un usage
des armes et ensuite on débrief des
groupes pour savoir si dans ce dans ce
cas de figure est-ce que le gendarmerie
pourquoi il aurait tiré pourquoi il
n'aurait pas tiré avait-il tort d'avoir
tiré enfin bref on essaye autant que
faire ce peu de le faire réfléchir à des
situations assez communes mais bien
évidemment cette dernière seconde elle
appartient à chacun et je crois que tant
qu'on l'a pas vécu on pourra faire tout
ce qu'on veut
c'est le propre de la dernière seconde
avec d'ailleurs toute la difficulté de
l'appréciation de cette dernière seconde
et de la notion notamment de légitime
défense
pour compléter
OK
peut-être
distinguer
quatre grands sujets dans les
différentes interventions madame
l'herbier monsieur Marc et Madame Marie
Bay vous avez évoqué les questions de
recrutement en pointant à la fois
l'aspect juridique et puis la nécessité
que nous avons aujourd'hui de recruter
des scientifiques alors même sujet que
pour nos camarades de la gendarmerie il
y a aujourd'hui un vrai challenge à
diversifier notre recrutement la police
nationale d'ailleurs probablement un peu
plus encore que la gendarmerie est très
souvent où se construit très souvent sur
des recrutements de juristes nous avons
beaucoup de candidats qui viennent des
yeuxp beaucoup de candidats qui viennent
de lieus de Paris sur les les concours
de cadre sup commissaire et officiers et
nous avons malheureusement encore peu de
scientifiques là où la gendarmerie
nationale a dans le cœur de ses concours
recrutement scientifique on fait un
effort de ce côté-là on fait un effort à
plusieurs niveaux d'abord à l'ouverture
des concours au sujet scientifiques on a
de plus en plus de suggestions
scientifiques dans les épreuves de
concours ce qui permet de de donner
aussi une place
à des élèves ou à des étudiants qui ont
cette dominante et puis nous avons aussi
avec les écoles d'ingénieurs des
ouvertures et des partenariats je le
mentionne c'est une école d'ingénieur
prestigieux ces Polytechnique la police
nationale forme depuis plusieurs années
maintenant des stagiaires
polytechniciens et notre ambition
aujourd'hui c'est d'arriver avec
Polytechnique mais aussi avec l'École
des Mines avec des écoles d'ingénieurs
un petit peu moins
réputés à recruter en dans un schéma qui
est un schéma d'école d'application à
recruter des cadres pour rentrer en
école de commissaire une école
d'officier pour l'instant on est
toujours au stade des des échanges avec
des concrétisations très prochaine je
pense notamment à l'accord de principe
qu'a donné le conseil d'administration
de Polytechnique au fait que assez
rapidement
n'ont pas cette année on risque d'être
un peu court par rapport à la
modification de l'eau des Crest
statutaires mais à tout coup l'an
prochain nous puissions avoir en école
d'application
des polytechniciens voire d'autres
d'autres ingénieurs dernier sujet sur le
recrutement des scientifiques sont les
contractuels alors préoccupations
partagées avec la gendarmerie évidemment
il est vrai que on a du mal à s'aligner
en termes de rémunération
ministre de l'Intérieur a donné des
instructions assez claires au service
pour que nous essayons d'être le plus
compétitif possible
nous avons aujourd'hui des programmes de
recrutement qui fonctionnent des
des ingénieurs qui nous rejoignent alors
le nomadisme professionnel qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui dans dans nos jeunes
générations s'appliquent assez
scientifiques comme à d'autres ils
passent chez nous pour deux ans trois
ans et puis et puis ils vont voir
ailleurs l'objectif que nous poursuivons
et ça a été vrai surtout dans le domaine
du renseignement c'est d'essayer de
faire en sorte de conserver ces profils
au moins dans le périmètre sécuritaire
c'est-à-dire de leur permettre de faire
un passage en gendarmerie demain en
police nationale et pourquoi pas dans le
renseignement puisque nous avons avec
nos services de renseignement là aussi
une offre très diversifiée alors restons
modeste c'est pas c'est pas aujourd'hui
quelque chose de totalement conduit ou
achevée c'est en cours mais ça marche
mieux qu'avant et nous avons de nous
avons de bons recrutements les juristes
ou la le recrutement de gardien de la
paix qui est un bagage juridique comme
le l'a dit le général art visait nous
avons beaucoup de candidats au concours
de gardiens de la paix qui ont plus que
le baccalauréat et qui ont acquis ce
bagage juridique ce qui explique sans
doute qu'elle issu du premier module de
formation dont parlait Philippe Lutz
tout à l'heure nous ayons déjà à peu
près 65% de réussite la culture
juridique est quand même une culture
assez assez bien ancrée deuxième sujet
qui a été évoqué et que je veux aborder
pour répondre à Monsieur Bourgis c'est
l'académie de police qui est un sujet
sur lequel je vais essayer d'être moins
prudent mais tout en restant quand même
dans les limites du mandat qui est le
mien vous expliquer bon que l'école de
Nîmes est l'un de nos plus c'est le plus
grand centre de formation et qu'il n'est
pas question que le projet d'académie de
police
j'allais dire mettre en difficulté ce
qui est aujourd'hui notre plus grand
centre je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que
notre un programme de recrutement est un
programme beaucoup plus important que
l'an passé donc l'école de Nîmes est une
une école qui a de beaux jours devant
elle alors en revanche l'académie de
police très concrètement à vocation à
accueillir le réseau de la formation et
les effectifs qui composent aujourd'hui
la Direction centrale du recrutement et
de la formation ont naturellement
vocation à rejoindre une académie de
police et à en être j'allais dire le
terreau de base ensuite il faut que nous
construisions avec cette académie des
programmes de formation continue je vous
l'ai dit pour les grader gardiens des
programmes de de recherche là et je veux
rester modeste parce que
il est pas question de de vous dorer la
pilule nous avons des progrès à
accomplir dans le domaine de la
recherche par rapport à ce que
certains de nos camarades peuvent faire
au national par rapport à ce que
certaines polices étrangères peuvent
faire on a là-dessus un champ à explorer
avec l'Académie de Police 7 académie de
police sera se creuser je vous ai parlé
d'un label parce que c'est un label qui
touchera l'ensemble du réseau de
formation mais ce sera aussi un creuset
de formation ce sera une j'allais dire
un bel établissement fait confiance à la
police nationale pour pour porter le
sujet comme il nous a été demandé deux
autres sujets ont été évoqués la
question des moyens et la question des
formations très spécifiques que ce soit
dans les domaines des violences
intra-familiales dans les domaines des
formations au gestes techniques et puis
dans le domaine essentiel qui est celui
des retours d'expérience à chaque fois
qu'il y a usage de l'arme et je laisse
Philippe Lutz développer ses points là
oui je vais commencer déjà par le
dernier point qui est un point essentiel
parce que quand on rentre dans la police
en quelque soit le corps de la
partenance mais c'est la même chose de
l'argent l'Armory il est pas tout à fait
naturel
de savoir porter une arme
de simplement avoir une arme dans la
main et de savoir ensuite s'en servir
c'est autre chose donc toute la
formation en formation initiale
principalement des gains de la paix mais
c'est le cas évidemment aussi des
officiers des commissaires de police
vise déjà à l'aptitude au port de l'arme
et pas seulement à savoir démonter une
arme mais savoir être à l'aise avec son
arme et donc les premières
les premières formations qui sont
organisées vise à ça alors on est
susceptible d'utiliser d'ailleurs dans
ce cadre là on teste actuellement
dans les écoles de police
particulièrement à Nîmes en lien avec la
sous-direction qui s'occupe de la
formation initiale des simulateurs de
tir et des simulateurs d'aide à la
décision qui doivent nous permettre dans
un premier temps peut-être pour les gens
qui sont complètement extérieur à la
police vous le savez gardien de la paix
il y a globalement la moitié du concours
qui est réservé à des internes mais en
fait il y a des faux externes qui sont
les policiers adjoints qui ont moins
d'un an mais qui ont déjà le bac et donc
qui passe le concours de gardien
tangente aux alentours à peu près de 60%
de interne donc cela globalement ils
n'ont pas de problème puisqu'ils ont
déjà eu cette formation par contre les
40% externes dans l'énorme majorité des
cas n'ont jamais porté d'armes et donc
comment fait-on pour leur permettre
d'avoir une attitude naturelle vis-à-vis
de l'arme sans être dans un espèce de
délire
vis-à-vis vis-à-vis de l'arme alors on a
à la fois ce dispositif qu'on met en
place avec les formateurs noter ici on a
aussi des psychologues puisque le réseau
des psychologues de la police nationale
ce sont pas des policiers purs ce sont
des contractuels et on a fait un effort
depuis deux ans en terme de recrutement
extrêmement important et ça ça aussi
très à la deuxième question sur comment
forme-t-on un certain nombre de choses
sur la relation à la personne la
désescalade le contrôle d'identité les
formateurs généralistes apportent leurs
connaissances juridiques leurs
connaissances de terrain les
psychologues apportent le contact avec
la personne comment on agit finalement
face à des personnalités différentes
encore une fois ce qui est ce qui est
extrêmement ce qui est extrêmement
important
juste quand même je pense que le sujet
de la formation initiale à l'arrivée
n'est sans doute pas le sujet essentiel
en la matière je vais vous citer un
exemple que vous connaissez tous parce
qu'il a été dramatique qui est l'affaire
Michael harpon Michael c'est la
préfecture de police il y a maintenant
quelques années je
relate pas le périple meurtrier de
Michael harpon je relate la fin
Michael harpon descend l'escalier un
escalier au coin de la préfecture de
police il se retrouve à face à un
fonctionneur de police qui est stagiaire
qui est sorti 15 jours avant de l'école
de Nîmes bon il se trouve que j'ai
discuté à plusieurs reprises avec ce
fonctionnaire très rapidement après les
feuilles et puis lors des obsèques et
puis à une autre occasion qu'on était
revenu à l'école de Nîmes puisqu'il
témoigne aussi à l'école de Nîmes on le
fait venir sur son vécu professionnel il
s'est littéralement remis dans une bulle
et par rapport à la question de monsieur
Sueur on est exactement là-dedans
combien de temps il avait pour se
remettre plein de choses la technique le
cadre juridique est-ce que je suis dans
la possibilité d'utiliser mon arme face
à un individu qui vient vers moi avec un
couteau à la main
buffet les sommations et je tire bon je
ne suis pas certain pour être clair que
un fonctionnaire qui aurait eu 15 ans
d'ancienneté aurait eu la même réaction
et surtout le même processus mental et
c'est tout l'enjeu d'une autre question
qui a été posée sur le nombre de tirs
globalement on a 60 65% des
fonctionnaires qui font leurs trois tirs
à l'année
ce qui est insuffisant naturellement
mais je dirais que et je l'ai déjà dit
au DGPN je l'ai déjà dit au directeur
territoriaux c'est le fait de se
concentrer sur les trois tirs on a un
certain nombre de chef de service qui
considère que la formation c'est un
objectif qui sont les trois tirs c'est
pour moi je j'ai quasiment être trivial
mais c'est quand même le degré zéro de
la réflexion en matière de formation
dire c'est beaucoup plus important de
savoir utiliser des techniques
d'interpellation moi j'ai été avant
d'être commissaire j'ai été inspecteur
j'ai été sur un département pendant 17
ans qui est intentionnait agité qui
s'appelle le 93 je n'ai jamais utilisé
mon arme par contre faire des
interpellations ça j'ai été plusieurs
fois soumis à l'obligation de les faire
et c'est beaucoup plus important de
savoir maîtriser ces techniques
d'interpellation et d'intervention et on
à ce que j'ai évoqué avant c'est-à-dire
que on peut programmer de manière quasi
institutionnelle des formations et tout
ça rien ne remplace le travail qui doit
être fait en proximité quand on forme
les brigadiers chefs
on les forme pas à voir cet aspect là
mais on peut aussi les former à quelques
gestes rappellent des rappels simples
sur l'utilisation de la force et ce qui
me semble encore une fois essentiel j'ai
eu l'occasion il y a quelques années de
discuter avec un préfet de police au
moment de la mise en place de la psq la
police de sécurité au quotidien c'est
essentiel de former les gens en école
sur la proximité tout ça je lui ai
répondu Monsieur le Préfet c'est fait il
y a de très nombreuses heures je
rappelle ce que j'ai dit avec les
psychologues sur le rapport à l'autre
sur le fait de pouvoir se maîtriser avec
notamment aussi des techniques ce qu'on
appelle les techniques
d'optimisation du potentiel qui sont des
techniques de relaxation de gestion du
stress et tout ça qu'on met en
maintenant dans les écoles de police de
gardien de ficiers et de commissaire de
police ce qui est plus important c'est
après c'est après quelle est
l'utilisation qui va être faite de cette
formation et comment elle va être
finalement mise en place répétée dans
les services c'est ça qui est encore une
fois qui est le plus important pour
répondre à une autre de vos questions
sur l'info centre dialogue les choses
vont un peu mieux
on va dire qu'elles sont quand même
encore largement perfectibles je vais
vous citer un exemple très précis on a
actuellement on a largement parlé de la
formation distancielle donc on a une
application qui s'appelle lui campus ou
tout est enregistré et on a une
application qui s'appelle dialogue qui
permet d'enregistrer
à la fois toutes les aspects RH et les
aspects formation bon dans un monde
parfait je fais ma formation sur les
campus je fais j'aime mon certificat qui
valide la formation et automatiquement
les données du campus sont basculés sur
dialogue mais le monde parfait n'existe
pas c'est à dire que actuellement ce
n'est pas le cas alors on travaille avec
la direction générale et la dénume et le
style pour mettre en place ça il y a un
certain nombre d'étapes
je suis raisonnablement optimiste pour
estimer que en 2024 on atteindra cet
élément là et cet élément il est pas
seulement pour le confort des agents
puisque là actuellement on a un système
de petite main de fourmis finalement qui
s'est qui ressaisissent dans dialogue ce
qui a déjà été enregistré dans dans le
campus qui est quand même pas
intellectuellement satisfaisant votre
cœur donc j'ai l'espoir qu'en 2024 on
pourra avoir une connexion directe du
campus vert dialogue pour permettre à la
fois d'améliorer la condition de travail
des gens mais aussi simplement de ne pas
perdre des formations ce qui pour moi
actuellement est assez évident c'est à
dire qu'on a un certain nombre de
formations qui sont réalisés par des
agents qui ne sont pas comptabilisés ce
qui n'est pas satisfaisant
je crois et puis sur la proximité pour
revenir alors vous êtes extrêmement gâté
dans le Nord puisque la majorité des
policiers sont
issus du Nord c'est à dire que le le la
zone géographique la plus attractive en
termes de recrutement c'est les
Hauts-de-France
devant l'Île-de-France qui théoriquement
concentre la majorité des des postes en
sortie d'école tant pour officier
commissaire que surtout gardien de la
paix alors pour pour reprendre ce que
vous évoquez sur les commissaires de
police on a développé un certain nombre
de dispositif pour préparer
au concours en lien avec les universités
on a 79 universités qui sont partenaires
et les écoles et les directions zonales
font un travail de préparation directe
avec des journées thématiques ou avant
de passer le concours on organise des
présentations des preuves
sur la zone Sud par exemple ça va plus
loin que ça puisqu'il y a une semaine
complète quasiment d'entraînement pour
les candidats externes parlent bien des
externes pour l'interne est déjà
beaucoup de choses qui sont faites mais
pour effectivement ne pas avoir
un prisme très français c'est-à-dire
tout se passe en Île-de-France
c'est-à-dire qu'on a beaucoup plus de
candidats en Île-de-France et je suis
complètement d'accord avec vous la
connaissance du territoire la
connaissance locale est extrêmement
important de voir fondamentale donc on
travaille beaucoup là-dessus encore une
fois avec des universités partenaires
pour essayer de récupérer bon alors
encore une fois les Hauts-de-France sont
particulièrement bien dotés moi je
regrette à titre personnel que l'est et
notamment l'Alsace se voit beaucoup
moins bien de thé mais on essaye
vraiment de travailler dans ce sens là
je ne sais pas si j'aurais répondu à
toutes les questions bien merci beaucoup
[Musique]
pas d'autres questions mais toutes les
réponses nous ont été apportées me
semble-t-il et de façon précise il me
reste monsieur à vous remercier d'être
venu à la commission des lois ce matin
et ainsi finalement de permettre à nos
deux rapports de voir terminer leur
travail mais surtout d'avoir informé
l'ensemble des commissaires de tu
travailles que vous faites et de la
situation et de la gendarmerie et de la
police en matière de formation Merci à
VOUS excellente journée